Caption: all right good evening and thanks for
Caption: having me here in Perth I lived in a
Caption: place called Brisbane out of the other
Caption: side of the desert and hoping to Perth
Caption: for a couple of years great place so
Caption: thanks again I'm going to tell you my
Caption: goal tonight is to tell you what
Caption: functional programming means just what
Caption: it means
Caption: mostly because I am sympathetic to you
Caption: if you typed into a search engine right
Caption: now what does it mean you'll get ten
Caption: wrong answers well unfortunately it's
Caption: it's it still has a bit of mysticism
Caption: around it and my one of my main goals of
Caption: coming here to Perth is to you know
Caption: spend three days with people who would
Caption: like to learn it in depth so I think
Caption: some of you are in this room we did our
Caption: mana edge tutorial today one adds a they
Caption: have a reputation for being difficult
Caption: they're not right wherever you are it's
Caption: just so that you don't write the same
Caption: code over and over again so that's done
Caption: and we'll go back to relaxing tomorrow
Caption: okay so I work for the Queensland
Caption: functional programming lab I am
Caption: it's a CSIRO and Queensland government
Caption: initiative and just to briefly say what
Caption: it is that I do I try to help Australian
Caption: software developers take advantage of
Caption: the benefits of functional programming
Caption: that's what I do and there's a team of
Caption: six of us I'm soon to be eleven I'm
Caption: hiring if you'd like to cross the desert
Caption: and come and write Haskell with me send
Caption: me an email so that's pretty much what I
Caption: do and it's quite fun writing open
Caption: source code helping out government
Caption: departments we've got all their data in
Caption: a mess and they're like help
Caption: oh yeah no worries I got Haskell
Caption: yes they we sort that out so I get this
Caption: I get this question quite a lot yeah so
Caption: I don't know if you have this question
Caption: but if you do how do what can I be
Caption: notified about the upcoming courses sign
Caption: up to that mailing list whenever I'm
Caption: going to Perth or Canberra or whatever
Caption: when we're going to do it that's I'll
Caption: write an email there and sometimes I get
Caption: this question like so these three days
Caption: I'm like I'm burning people really hard
Caption: right am i right
Caption: yeah I'm right I'm like I'm drilling you
Caption: hard but we're gonna get to the end of
Caption: it and you're gonna say to me how do I
Caption: write a web app in Haskell right or
Caption: something like this so that's that
Caption: that's what we're doing that now
Caption: so if you're interested in that so
Caption: you've been burnt you've learned all the
Caption: introductory stuff you're ready to go
Caption: how do I write a database where that
Caption: whatever it is you want to do so we're
Caption: doing that this year
Caption: and yes I do yes we do six of us let
Caption: alone it so I've just a background on
Caption: how I got into functional programming I
Caption: used to work for IBM and I asked these
Caption: days to implement is language called
Caption: Java if you ever heard of it
Caption: basically you got to write a compiler
Caption: and it compiles your code that was my
Caption: job and there was a company called Sun
Caption: Microsystems back then so I had to
Caption: implement this thing called Java I
Caption: learnt it as much as I needed to so that
Caption: I could write all the Camellia compiler
Caption: and specifications and so on and it was
Caption: it was a simple thought that I assume
Caption: everyone has had every programmer at
Caption: least has had which is simply surely
Caption: there's a better way okay so you know
Caption: Java programmers in the room you've all
Caption: seen like null pointer exceptions and
Caption: you've seen all this stuff and you're
Caption: like do I really have to meet you with
Caption: this really and you need to develop a
Caption: process to answer this question and my
Caption: process was someone smarter than me has
Caption: figured this out
Caption: who are these smart people and the smart
Caption: people I found out where the functional
Caption: programmers they've already figured this
Caption: out they figured out how to not have
Caption: enough functional corner exceptions
Caption: right and so on they've worked out how
Caption: to do it and I'm gonna go and steal all
Caption: their ideas that's pretty much it so
Caption: when I when I first moved to Brisbane in
Caption: like 2003 or four I think there were two
Caption: of us writing Haskell in Brisbane and we
Caption: found each other because I appeared in
Caption: the television interview and the other
Caption: person said hey that's the person off
Caption: the Haskell mailing list
Caption: he lives in Brisbane there's two of us
Caption: and it kind of went from there that's a
Caption: true story
Caption: so functional programming is certainly
Caption: my opinion on how to do software
Caption: development so I'm going to tell you
Caption: what it means what does it mean common
Caption: question so I'm going to show you a
Caption: computer program this is a this is in
Caption: any syntax no particular language and if
Caption: we look at this this this procedure up
Caption: here and we notice first of all it adds
Caption: one to the counter some counter
Caption: somewhere and then it returns a plus B
Caption: times two and then the arbitrary code
Caption: stands for the rest of the application
Caption: all right fifty billion lines of
Caption: whatever it is and then you come across
Caption: this expression down here alright and
Caption: you look at this and you go okay
Caption: there's some code duplication right
Caption: there can i factor that code duplication
Caption: out without affecting the program can I
Caption: do that
Caption: did the program just change it did yeah
Caption: it changed why did it change it changed
Caption: because the counter used to update twice
Caption: because there were two calls to the
Caption: wibble function or procedure and now
Caption: there's one so the counter only updates
Caption: once the program changed
Caption: I cannot take an expression factor it
Caption: out naively and get the same program in
Caption: this particular circumstance and it's
Caption: because of that so if I take that out
Caption: and look at this exact same program and
Caption: I say there's some code duplication
Caption: can i factor it out I can the program
Caption: didn't change that is the same program
Caption: isn't that great
Caption: it didn't change and that's because it
Caption: is a function Whittle or pebble in this
Caption: case is a function there's a function
Caption: because given the inputs it'll return
Caption: the same output and do nothing else okay
Caption: sure which one this one here yeah yeah
Caption: yeah well this is the original program
Caption: so the question I'm asking is if I
Caption: change this program into that program
Caption: did it change from the previous one into
Caption: this one it does in this case yeah it
Caption: didn't in the other case you agree with
Caption: that do I have your agreement on these
Caption: things because if so because because it
Caption: is the same program or the reason it's
Caption: the same program is because people is a
Caption: function there is no additional effect
Caption: going on okay so the program didn't
Caption: change in the second circumstance
Caption: because there was a function and that's
Caption: because given the same output inputs to
Caption: get same outputs with no other changes
Caption: caring that is to say we can replace an
Caption: expression with its value naively and
Caption: always get the same program that is
Caption: functional programming Mike drops a
Caption: letter
Caption: I'm dead set that is the definition of
Caption: functional programming the extent to
Caption: which I can replace expressions with
Caption: values without changing program behavior
Caption: that's a very simple definition and that
Caption: the property of expressions when they
Caption: when you can do this with expressions is
Caption: sometimes called referential
Caption: transparency so we'd say that that
Caption: expression back back earlier the pibil
Caption: one that is a referentially transparent
Caption: expression whereas the wibble one was
Caption: not i cannot substitute it with its
Caption: value and get the same same outcome so
Caption: so what why does the government pay me
Caption: to care a lot about that it's because of
Caption: the consequences so who users like you
Caption: know JavaScript and Java and Python and
Caption: c-sharp all these languages right you
Caption: can be counter equals counter plus one
Caption: no worries and off you go
Caption: I can't that's one of the consequences
Caption: straight away you can't do this right in
Caption: whatever language it is you use you've
Caption: got an object with mutable fields in
Caption: there I can't do that right you can even
Caption: do that I can't do that if I say I equal
Caption: to 0 I will always equal 0 it's the end
Caption: of the argument if you come along and go
Caption: I plus plus it will not compile Haskell
Caption: will not compile that so hang on a
Caption: minute
Caption: I equals 0 ie plus plus
Caption: contradiction
Caption: um I I have two children when my son was
Caption: nine years old I had the following
Caption: discussion that went like this if C plus
Caption: three equals seven what's C and he said
Caption: what it's for oh yeah okay well if X
Caption: times five equals 25 what's X he said
Caption: well it's five and I said if I equals
Caption: zero and then I equals I plus 1 what's I
Caption: you said that makes no sense
Caption: I said correct I have it I have it on
Caption: mp3 if you'd like to listen to it I did
Caption: not prod him at all that exists
Caption: one morning I just started saying that
Caption: so you can't do that in because this
Caption: expression here I plus plus is not
Caption: referentially transparent you cannot
Caption: substitute I throughout the program and
Caption: get the same program they're all
Caption: different eyes you can't do this common
Caption: question I get does that mean you can't
Caption: do I oh well of course I can I just
Caption: can't you know do it messily like this I
Caption: can't just arbitrarily do it I can't
Caption: just start doing these things right if I
Caption: if I replace read file with the filename
Caption: with its value I'd get a different
Caption: program right it had read the file once
Caption: and then that's it all right
Caption: that would just it would change the
Caption: program outcome if I were to substitute
Caption: that expression there read file file
Caption: name with its value so if I live three
Caption: days by the way that we're spending is
Caption: I've taken away all these tools from you
Caption: know 30 people in the room who are so
Caption: used to like read file write file I plus
Caption: plus everything's just fine and I've
Caption: just taken all of that away from them
Caption: and they're standing there naked like
Caption: how do I solve all these problems now
Caption: and I substituting new problem solving
Caption: tools and causes some pain but that's
Caption: okay it is okay right it's a little bit
Caption: of pain
Caption: yeah not too much I'll give you an
Caption: example these are some of the questions
Caption: that we were immediately asked once I
Caption: take away all your where your tools will
Caption: we will be answering that third question
Caption: tomorrow by the way how do we design our
Caption: data structures how do I can't have
Caption: mutable fields anymore
Caption: what do I do how do I write loops how do
Caption: I even sum the values of a list alright
Caption: so if you've never heard a functional
Caption: programming how do you sum the values in
Caption: a list how do you do it oh you've heard
Caption: a functional programming you go x equals
Caption: zero for each element in the list x
Caption: equals x plus the element return x am i
Caption: right something like this if I remember
Caption: rightly last time I wrote a for loop
Caption: it's something like that so set the
Caption: counter at zero or a start position a
Caption: zero go through the list for each
Caption: element add the counter to that element
Caption: return the counter it's the sum of the
Caption: lists but there's a different way of
Caption: thinking about this problem so this is
Caption: an example of I'm going to take away
Caption: this I've taken away loops they don't
Caption: exist and we're going to sum up the
Caption: elements of the list and I did hear
Caption: someone say recursion and that's how
Caption: we're going to do it
Caption: so these things are disallowed okay if I
Caption: set R equal to zero what's our it's zero
Caption: end of argument so that this thing here
Caption: is not a thing if I set I equal to 0 its
Caption: 0 that would be a very uninteresting
Caption: program R equals 0 equals 0 at the end
Caption: so there's another way of looking at the
Caption: problem of adding up the integers of a
Caption: list and it it's this if the list is
Caption: empty return zero but if it's not then
Caption: return the first element plus the sum of
Caption: the rest of the list does everyone agree
Caption: that that adds up all the integers in a
Caption: list so basically we have a list and
Caption: Alyssa can be displayed into two
Caption: possible cases is it empty or does it
Caption: have a first element and the rest of the
Caption: list that's the definition of a list in
Caption: Haskell in fact I could show you the
Caption: code I don't have a pair Boca shades
Caption: just basically is empty or has the start
Caption: element and then the rest of the list
Caption: that's the definition of the datatype so
Caption: stepping through that that definition
Caption: let's add up a list and we say well is
Caption: that list six five nine seventy one
Caption: three is it empty no well then the sum
Caption: of it is six plus the sum of the rest
Caption: and so on until we get down to the sum
Caption: of the empty list and we say well is it
Caption: empty yes and then we substitute to zero
Caption: and then at and then the sum of all of
Caption: that is 94 and at no time did I say I
Caption: equals zero oh wait no it doesn't it's I
Caption: equals I plus one
Caption: there's the Haskell code who's not a
Caption: programmer can you read that
Caption: just curious I'll explain it to you and
Caption: then you answer for me all right
Caption: so the sum of an empty list is equals 0
Caption: the sum of a list that has the first
Caption: element in the rest is the first element
Caption: plus the sum of the rest I think that's
Caption: pretty straightforward who's not a
Caption: programmer and can read that I struggle
Caption: myself a zero oh wait no it's not hang
Caption: on that's how I read that k my common
Caption: criticism of functional programming is
Caption: that it's unintuitive I'm kind of
Caption: mocking that criticism lies my
Caption: nine-year-old disagrees so what say yeah
Caption: this is a good question
Caption: much more serious question which is why
Caption: would I even care all right you might be
Caption: over there writing your loop see like
Caption: I'm totally cool with loops I'm summing
Caption: up the list everything's just fine leave
Caption: me alone all right what I'm saying but
Caption: there's practical benefits what are they
Caption: and this is quite a deep question I'm
Caption: happy to answer it for days and days and
Caption: days if you like but I don't have that
Caption: much but I'll do my best in the short
Caption: amount of time so they're not obvious
Caption: and it's like it's the people who are in
Caption: this three-day course it's still not
Caption: obvious I think so we're up to date it's
Caption: still not obvious but just to give it a
Caption: hand wavy overview right so and ender
Caption: there's a penalty
Caption: the penalty is I've taken away all your
Caption: familiar tools so you're trusting me
Caption: right now and I completely appreciate
Caption: that I've taken away all the good things
Caption: and I've not yet given you any well I'm
Caption: not giving you anything good to
Caption: substitute them all back
Caption: but I can reason about programs okay
Caption: so again this is a hand wave you think I
Caption: could concrete this in if at the time
Caption: but basically looking at the definition
Caption: of some in Haskell let's go back and
Caption: have a look at that actually the Sun so
Caption: for example if I look at this program I
Caption: can reason about for example that line
Caption: independently of that line there are two
Caption: discrete programs and they exist
Caption: independently and I've just put them
Caption: together to make a new one not only that
Caption: to do this one
Caption: I've taken the plus function and that
Caption: value and that function and made a new
Caption: one and did the sum function delete the
Caption: database no it can't
Caption: now you might go well that's insane
Caption: some functions don't delete databases
Caption: and I would say yes they do you've
Caption: surely worked on this project where
Caption: there's some function deleted the
Caption: database right anyone's been doing
Caption: programming long enough guys who put
Caption: that there that's insane it updates to
Caption: fling and floppin whatever it is right
Caption: we know these programs they exist they
Caption: can't exist here they're discrete units
Caption: it's usually like not deleting the
Caption: databases like inserting a database row
Caption: I'll wait now there's two of them whoops
Caption: something like this happens or updates
Caption: the XML configuration file whatever I
Caption: don't Carn exist here these are discrete
Caption: units and I can exact and reason about
Caption: them independently not there I can't our
Caption: equals zero oh wait no it doesn't and so
Caption: on but I have to do the whole thing all
Caption: at once
Caption: I can't reason about that discreetly the
Caption: plus function I can and I mean plus
Caption: function I can because it's a function
Caption: the things that are not functions I
Caption: can't
Caption: and say oops so the other one is
Caption: composition so it's basically if I have
Caption: discrete units of programs I can glue
Caption: them together to make slightly less
Caption: smaller units and I can keep going so
Caption: and by that I mean that they're discrete
Caption: I take another discrete unit blew it
Caption: together I have another just another
Caption: small unit and then I can take another
Caption: one and so on as opposed to the monolith
Caption: program so who's got a monolith program
Caption: at work just by the way just come on
Caption: let's be a bit honest so everyone's got
Caption: one right there's the monolith program
Caption: expert on your team yeah you're like hey
Caption: you know the project manager wants to
Caption: add you add a widget in the corner and
Caption: you go what happens when I go and
Caption: twiddle the code this way and add the
Caption: widget you go on ask the expert as well
Caption: yeah it'll take six months whatever you
Caption: know all that that's true
Caption: yes it's like what you want to add a
Caption: widget no way we can't do that all it'll
Caption: be a rewrite yeah that's really what
Caption: happens so that's because at least I'm
Caption: going to I'm trying to claim that the
Caption: program is not in discrete units of
Caption: composition it's just a model with a
Caption: depends on B on C on D and back again
Caption: around a and so on in the expert tries
Caption: to hold rule in their head I've never
Caption: met an expert that actually can but they
Caption: try and good on them but it's so
Caption: difficult that you hit a scalability
Caption: problem with your development and you
Caption: just that's the size of your program
Caption: forever and that's why they say no
Caption: you're not adding the widget and and and
Caption: I'll be honest I've worked on one a list
Caption: don't worry I've written them myself
Caption: so it takes a lot of work okay those of
Caption: you are up to date ooh good on you
Caption: all right I have set you on fire many
Caption: times and I understand this and a little
Caption: bit sorry but not a lot because there's
Caption: benefits all right so those you are not
Caption: not there you know I am hurting people a
Caption: lot we have completed that there's a
Caption: there's a course called the CIS one line
Caption: for undergraduate introduction to high
Caption: school at the University of Pennsylvania
Caption: it's online you can go and do that right
Caption: now and we've just done that in two days
Caption: all right so that's that's how hard I'm
Caption: hurting people because it's a lot of
Caption: work so what I'm getting at is is if you
Caption: were to ever commit to taking advantage
Caption: of these things in your programming you
Caption: would have to do a lot of work make no
Caption: mistake about it but I'm committed to
Caption: helping you that's what I want to do all
Caption: right so I will hold your hand when you
Caption: fall I'll pick you up and we'll keep
Caption: going and through the trenches and we'll
Caption: get to the other end and you feel like
Caption: ah ha I know what I'm 1 AD means and now
Caption: I can take advantage of these things
Caption: that's my job that's my goal and join me
Caption: thank you for listening
Caption: let's go I'm afraid Lee has had to run
Caption: off so tonight I imagine that Tony is
Caption: happy to take a couple little questions
Caption: absolutely and possibly our speakers are
Caption: as well but maybe what we should do
Caption: instead is in a bit of a pat-down and
Caption: may be moving across to something like
Caption: cheeky Sparrow that might be a good
Caption: opportunity for a lot of questions that
Caption: haven't so perhaps we could just ask one
Caption: or two if anybody has something that
Caption: they would particularly like to ask Tony
Caption: and then he found other speakers would
Caption: like to join us later or as down yep and
Caption: that way we can wrap it up because I
Caption: know it has been quiet on that is there
Caption: any questions yeah why should I use
Caption: hostel rather than do programming in a
Caption: functional style of normal good question
Caption: I get it I get it so I I strongly
Caption: encourage you to try it and I have tried
Caption: it I could show you the code I've done
Caption: it in Java C sharp and Python and
Caption: JavaScript and Scala here forget that
Caption: say that if you do try it you'll have
Caption: additional problems all right so I would
Caption: argue that it's certainly in an
Caption: educational environment it's already
Caption: hard enough but suppose you like you're
Caption: over that you're like yep I've got this
Caption: covered I'm going to go and use
Caption: JavaScript or something and the problem
Caption: is you'll start hitting JavaScript
Caption: problems right so for example that's
Caption: some function that I showed you before
Caption: if you go and write that in JavaScript
Caption: right now I'm going to give it a list
Caption: with 10,000 elements it'll build up a
Caption: stack of 10,000 and then bang Stack
Caption: Overflow okay so that's not to say just
Caption: that's you know stop right there don't
Caption: do anything and go back to what you're
Caption: doing before it's that you then have to
Caption: recognize those penalties exist so you
Caption: can't just naively write a sum function
Caption: anymore
Caption: you have to be aware of JavaScript's
Caption: limitations and this is pretty much true
Caption: for many other of those languages but I
Caption: do encourage you to try and get the
Caption: Stack Overflow and go or what do I do
Caption: now
Caption: yeah and in fact one of the projects
Caption: that so one of the open-source projects
Caption: on my team is to help you overcome that
Caption: so if a Python and soon-to-be JavaScript
Caption: right which is basically I have this
Caption: problem which is I can convince you that
Caption: functional programming is the bee's
Caption: knees right now and you were completely
Caption: convinced but you've got a million lines
Caption: of Python back at work
Caption: well JavaScript or whatever and there's
Caption: nothing I can do that can just say well
Caption: just stop work right now throw all that
Caption: code away and let's start again because
Caption: that's imposing quite a big penalty and
Caption: I want to try and make that penalty
Caption: small even zero yeah I just wanted to
Caption: say thanks so much for didi Perth for
Caption: organizing this event tonight it's been
Caption: awesome I've been to their main
Caption: conference before it's fabulous right
Caption: I'm actually here for IT professionals
Caption: Association I have invited members of
Caption: that group to come along tonight an
Caption: experienced DDD
Caption: and hopefully help us go through our
Caption: journey of representing more than just
Caption: one kind of IT professional because we
Caption: started out as a group for system
Caption: administrators we have got a horrid
Caption: perspective now we're more about
Caption: representing technical professionals if
Caption: anyone is more into policy or managed
Caption: then ACS is probably a better
Caption: organization but if you want a group
Caption: that could help you look for a job help
Caption: you up skill to get a better job or help
Caption: you in negotiations with your employer
Caption: as well as just helping you get a sense
Caption: of like friendship from other IT people
Caption: that you can go to meetings with then
Caption: speak to me afterwards and ask me about
Caption: the ITP a Thank You Alastair by the way
Caption: so look thank you everyone for coming
Caption: down to this office db5 we have
Caption: announced our conference date it is the
Caption: fourth movement we have oceans our
Caption: ticket sales yesterday and we have
Caption: opened our call for presentations
Caption: yesterday as well tonight we had three
Caption: very different talks very entertaining
Caption: talks as well and I want to say thank
Caption: you once again to our three speakers but
Caption: such a a wonderful I guess
Caption: representation of the breadth of talks
Caption: that you can expect to see as a DD per
Caption: event if you are at all interested in
Caption: learning more about dee dee deep earth
Caption: then speak to someone in agreement shirt
Caption: and I highly encourage you to come up
Caption: and say thank you to each one of our
Caption: free speakers and especially if you
Caption: would like to learn some more about
Caption: their talks tonight please
Caption: with them why don't work as we pack down
Caption: I also had what two other things to say
Caption: first of all you'll notice these great
Caption: orange banners here both west where we
Caption: art they are such a fantastic supporter
Caption: of software community and we wouldn't be
Caption: doing today is event without them so
Caption: thank you once again to Bank West for
Caption: such a fantastic venue and support we
Caption: have also just discovered or sorry I've
Caption: just announced our our platinum sponsor
Caption: for deeper have we you know you're
Caption: looking surprised and so actually when I
Caption: comes across the interview and who our
Caption: platinum sponsors and that's I guess the
Caption: entire year of dating
Caption: we also have a lemon so I just wanted to
Caption: shout and make eat very much to fan as
Caption: well I think that's really it for us
Caption: thank you once again for coming on down
Caption: and
Caption: you
Caption: [Applause]